hi I'm Kristen Bell I played Veronica
Mars I'm Kirby how about please and I
playing the Coleman [ __ ] run come on
hey I'm Ryan Hansen and I played dick
hey what's up I'm Percy Jackson third I
play Wallace for now hi I'm Jason
Doering played Logan echoes Mars Francis
capper I play eli weevil Navarro
I'm Enrico Colantoni and I play Keith
Mars on Veronica Mars
and we are about to play a game of who's
who
[Music]
am i pointing at Percy yes that's why
should be because he really is the nice
guy
yeah he's a nice guy yeah in some ways
well none of the dick of day sure okay
and you're a great dad
that's yeah so we buy there but as far
as fun and like toughing a party oh yeah
oh that's a tie that's a tie between you
two I've ever this group but I've been
her yeah cuz her character is tough as
nails and like you know she's up she's
the owner of a bar and she kicks ass and
punches people that's right yeah and I
am genuinely at Ramona I still wanna be
Syria yeah also I make the final ruling
so delete is irrelevant Francis I was
gonna say Francis yeah well he's not
here so we can say that Francis used
late today
yeah well so are you Kristen Kristen's
pretty yeah she's pretty long on
Instagram if I have 20 ml followers I
probably on there a lot to it is for
work do I look like I used to do I used
to take a paper bowl and line it with
peanut butter do you remember yes line
the whole like peanut butter stick
coating and then put a whipped cream all
over it and like a half a bottle of
whipped cream and then top it with
blueberries she would always have stuff
I wanted I would be like oh yeah you
have to take I've good ideas she was
always there there in in quacks though
apple slices with the peanut butter
did I change my life oh God
so little things you know
gimme Kristen Esselstyn Asmus you're
alive every - yes look I I remember her
coming into like she's like I haven't
read this
yeah it just killed it although you know
I have to say in season four our life is
a little bigger
mm-hmm you got kids I'll point to myself
because I love naps yeah yeah I didn't
even know that is an area I give
unsolicited advice that every once
although hadn't kind of myself do I
think oh yeah I've had a little bit of
advice from her over this oh I do yeah
I don't know if it's even advice but
like I will I will talk to you about
whatever you need to say well I'm gonna
say Kristen again because she's such a
good mimic and she is she's the one
that's worked with all of us and some of
us haven't worked together yes well
maybe because I'm like a tiny bit of a
minute but I've never like turning to
you guys
oh I can only do people who are a little
over the top like like I could do to get
some burgers like Mugen
it's not me character yeah that again
[Music]